nouveauté en matière de sécurité
routière qui fait grincer les dents
désormais les pv pour conduite avec
alcool devront prendre en compte une
marge d'erreur liés aux éthylotests
c'est le cisr info qui nous explique
tout cela c'est un jugement qui va à
l'encontre de la sévérité envers
l'alcool au volant la cour de cassation
a rendu obligatoire la prise en compte
de la marge d'erreur lors des contrôles
d'alcoolémie
jusqu'à lors le taux autorisé était de 0
40 mg par litre d'alcool dans l'air
expiré
désormais elle sera de 0 44 mg par litre
une personne contrôlée à 0,41 mg par
litre ne sera plus sanctionné d'une
suspension de permis de conduire de six
mois mais d'une simple contravention
cette limite équivaut environ à deux
verres de vin en fonction du poids de la
personne des milliers d'automobilistes
devrait donc échapper à des poursuites
l'arrêt est effective pour toutes les
procédures en cours une nouvelle
position de la cour de cassation alors
même que l'alcool est la deuxième cause
de mortalité sur les routes
je rappelle quand même qu'un tiers des
accidents mortels sur la route sont dus
à l'alcool que l'alcool multiplie par
8,5 fois le risque de causer un accident
mortel c'est énorme et que c'est donc
une des premières causes d'accidents sur
la route qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette latitude qui va être aujourd'hui
en mise en place car oui eh ben je me
demande s'il ya une marge d'erreur sur
la connerie
ah oui carrément voilà donc non mais
pourquoi je dis ça parce que vous venez
quand même tous les jours dans des
messages de il ne faut pas boire on a
encore une nouvelle campagne contre
l'alcool etc
et là ça va complètement à l'encontre et
de la logique et de ce qu'on essaye tous
de faire pour réduire votre consommation
d'alcool parce qu'on a compris que
c'était dangereux donc à quel moment
maintenant en 2019
on allège encore à la peine alors que
c'est la première alors on dit que c'est
miley c'est lié aux éthylotests et que
donc il y aurait cette fameuse marge
d'erreur comme parfois sur les radars
vous savez on dit plus ou moins 5 km
es22 plus haute ville et dans ces cas là
c'est en train d'envoyer des messages
drôlement bizarre parce que on a mis du
temps à faire imposer cette notion du
sam le gars qui buvaient pas pendant la
soirée pour ramener ses copains là on a
deux problèmes ont à celui là cette cour
de cassation qui vient de donner une
marge d'erreur à la consommation
d'alcool
et puis la pub dont tu viens de parler
sur l'alcool moi je la trouve super
bizarre rappelle que c'est une fille qui
dit 2
deux aires d'alcool c'est bon mais ça
veut dire que tu peux boire deux verres
d'un clown c'est presque si on te
conseille de boire deux verres d'alcool
et je trouve ça complètement délirant
dès que vous buvez de l'alcool vous avez
une altération de des conditions dans
lesquelles vous vous conduisez
donc on a mis du temps à obtenir ça et
là les messages sont complètement
brouillé ça va pas du tout est ce que
vous voudriez aller jusqu'à la tolérance
zéro comme dans certains pays
emilie ben oui bien évidemment moi j'ai
jamais caché le fait que pour moi alcool
et conduite ne vont pas du continent
semblent j'ai énormément de respect pour
la cour de cassation mais là c'est
crétin inconscient et criminels sexuels
c'est criminel ce qu'ils font parce que
le message qu'ils envoient sem si on
vous dit à la marge on passe de corey
haim 49 oui bafin la marge les gens qui
meurent sur les routes par an il ya un
mec qui est complètement bourrés qui
leur fonce dedans
la main ils s'en foutent un petit peu et
là le message qu'on envoie aux gens
c'est vous inquiétez pas les gars de
toute façon vous avez une petite latence
une petite marge donc au pire si vous
buvez vos deux verres bon c'est pas bien
grave l'éthylotest on s'arrangera ya pas
de problème si les entrées dans ce
message vous en tout cas c'est
exactement ça que j'entends encore je le
répèterai jamais assez moi mon père est
mort comme ça sur la route voilà à cause
de l'alcool au volant
donc c'est quelque chose qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur et ces gens là
avec tout le respect que je leur dois
j'ai envie de les gifler j'ai envie de
chialer d'entendre ce genre de chose qui
est de dire aux gens voilà vous pouvez
boire au volant c'est pas possible il ya
plein de pays en europe qui le qui
applique la tolérance zéro vous n'êtes
pas là tolérant et moi je suis
totalement 01 col rond bien sûr si tu
conduis tu ne vois pas c'est tout et
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas mon permis
complètement on peut pas dire
complètement sa de la cour de cassation
la cour de cassation si aisément qu'ils
jugent sur des éléments pertinents et
c'est donc mais par contre moi je suis
persuadé qu'à l'heure actuelle il ya une
pression forte
je suis pas conspirationnistes du tout
mais des lobbys de l'industrie du vin
parce que c'est vrai qu'à une régression
de la consommation du vin et de l'alcool
d'une façon générale à cause des
messages qu'on avait envoyé deux pieds
vous pensez que c'est lié aux lauriers
il ya des trucs un peu bizarres pas la
cour de cassation mais je pense que la
pub que j'ai vu moi je la trouve
hallucinante regardez là vous me direz
si j'entends tout à fait l'histoire des
milices
respecte totalement et c'est maintenant
là c'est une marge d'erreur dont on
parle donc forcément ça peut être utile
pour des gens qui en france on a le
droit de boire deux verres donc voila
moi ça m'est arrivé de boire 3 4 verres
et de souffler dans le ballon et d'être
à 0 et à linverse j'ai des amis mais
aussi parce que parce que c'est bidon
parce que alors leur sixième c'est ce
que leurs systèmes leur système pour
soupe de d'éthylotests ne fonctionne pas
à tous les coups et loin de là donc
cette marge d'erreur ces voix là pour se
donner un peu de latence par rapport aux
problèmes de justice juridique ou procès
qui pourrait y avoir c'est tout mais son
message confirmer qu'effectivement on
peut parfois on peut tromper
l'éthylotest alors c'est pas en
soufflant mais il ya trois ans de ça il
y avait des éthylotests qui était il y
avait une rupture avec la manche
ça veut dire que si vous suscitez des
pastilles de menthe alors à ce moment là
où des pastilles pour le tabac qui
contenait un sucre alcool
ça perturbe l éthylotest et donc vous
pouviez boire 3 4 5 verres de vin et le
gendarme vous redire distribués à la
sortie des boîtes de nuit tu es là
l'école on voit bien que vous êtes
bourrés mais il ya la sortie des boîtes
de nuit en effet en avait plein et quand
je dis ça je témoigne parce que j'ai des
dizaines dizaines de daiwa c'est
terrible la même expérience et après ce
que je veux dire c'est qu'en effet
l'alcool sur la route c'est dramatique
ça tue environ 1000 personnes par an
mais sauf que c'est pas malheureusement
le problème majeur en france on a
l'impression qu'on met tous les moyens
dessus la grippe tue plus le travail tue
plus ri mais il n'en est en fait aussi
un problème là il assure avoir les
moyens de chauffage et puis jean les
virus ne dis pas ça va supprimer les
virus
ça veut dire qu'on ne peut pas éliminer
les journées tu peux y met et milhac
totalement raison tu peux éliminer la
raison pour laquelle tu es menacé de
mort et c'est un récit une réalité marc
sauf part je vous entends qui
s'intéresse au passé sur le zéro non il
faut aller poser la question de
téléspectateurs une marge d'erreur des
contrôles d'alcool au volant est ce que
vous trouvez cela normal ou pas normal
visiblement emilie ils sont de votre
côté pour 65% d'entre eux près normal
mais normal pour 35% donc de votre côté